cuál es los siguientes números son
factores de 154 y aquí tengo en 3 al 5
al 6 al 9 y el 14 así que el primero
pongamos aquí al 154 154 y yo me
pregunto por los factores de 154 un
número es factor de 154 si podemos
dividir al 154 entre ese número y
obtenemos un residuo de 0 o también
podemos pensarlo de la siguiente manera
un número es factor de 154 654 es
múltiplo de ese número por ejemplo el 3
el 3 divide al 154 am si nosotros
recordamos el criterio de visibilidad
del 3 podemos decir que la suma de estos
dígitos tiene que ser divisible entre 3
para que 154 sea divisible entre 3 156
más 4 es 10 por lo tanto 154 no es
divisible entre 3 pero inclusive podemos
también probar
imagínate que no recuerdo el criterio de
divisibilidad del 3
y entonces agarró el 154 y digo 154
entre 3 a 5 5 por 3 es 15 15 los restos
me sobran 0 y bajo el 4 y digo 3 cabe
una vez en 4 3 por 13 para 4 y me sobra
1 por lo tanto mi residuo es 1 en este
caso como en mi residuo no es cero
entonces el 3 no es un factor de 154 así
que podemos cancelarlo ahora qué pasa
con el 5 bueno si nosotros pensamos en
el 5 te vas a dar cuenta que todo el
número que es múltiplo de 5 acaba en 5 o
en 0 5 10 15 20 siempre acabamos en 5 o
en cero o en 5 o en 0 por lo tanto 154
no es un múltiplo de 5 porque no acaba
en 5 o en 0 entonces podemos decir que
el 5 no es un factor de 154 el 5 no va a
dividir de manera exacta
54 ahora pensemos en el 6 el 6 es
múltiplo de 3 y si es múltiplo de 3 de
una manera muy rápida podemos concluir
que no es factor de 154 si el 3 no fue
factor de 154 el 6 tampoco va a ser
factor de 154 porque el 6 es múltiplo de
3 entonces este tampoco es factor de 154
el 9 por la misma manera no es factor de
154 recuerda que el 9 es un factor de 3
el 9 tiene que ver con el 3 y por lo
tanto si el 3 no es factor de 154 el 9
tampoco lo es y el 14
bueno vamos a dividir entre 14 a ver qué
me queda 154 lo voy a dividir entre 14
entre 14 15 cabe una vez entre 14 1 por
14 humedad 14 y aquí le pongo un 9 menos
aquí me sobra un 1 y bajo un 4 14 entre
14 cabe una vez 14 por 14 14 lo resto y
me sobran 0 por lo tanto como tengo un
residuo de 0 entonces estoy diciendo que
14 sigue
un factor de 154 porque justo eso es lo
que pedían que tuviéramos un residuo de
0 entonces mi respuesta es 14 de estos
números 14 es el único factor de 154
ahora déjame hacer otro problema muy
similar entonces para esto déjame borrar
todo esto que tengo aquí déjame ver si
puedo borrar todo esto que tengo aquí
borremos lo ok vamos a quitar también
este problema anterior
no quiero este ni quiero este pero sí
quiero el siguiente problema y el
siguiente problema es este cuál de los
siguientes números es múltiplo de 14 y
tengo los siguientes números 69 70 75 80
y 85 y bueno esencialmente hay dos
formas de resolver este problema la
primera y lo que se me ocurre es dividir
69 entre 14 y ver si es exacto dividir
70 entre 14 y ver si es exacto 75 entre
1480 entre 14 y 80 y 50 14 pero también
hay otra forma y creo que es mucho más
rápida para ver si estos números son
múltiplos de 14 y para esto lo que voy a
hacer es buscar los múltiplos de 14 es
decir me voy a tomar el 14 y voy a ver
quiénes son sus múltiplos 14 por unas 14
y 14 por 2 14 por 2 es 28 28 también es
un múltiplo de 14 y 14 por 3 pues bueno
es 28 14 lo cual me da 12 llevamos 112
es 31 es 4 42 también es un múltiplo de
14 y si a esto le sumamos 14 me va a dar
6 56 56 también es un múltiplo de 14 y
si a esto le sumamos 14 me va a dar 0 y
llevamos 11 y 5 son 6 y 1 son 7 70 y si
a esto le sumamos 14 m 84 y así no puedo
seguir y seguir y seguir
ahora date cuenta que creo que ya
tenemos la respuesta de este problema
porque porque date cuenta que aquí lo
primero que vemos es que 70 70 si es
múltiplo de 14 por lo tanto este si es
múltiplo de 14 69 no lo es
75 tampoco lo es tampoco llegamos a 75
80 tampoco lo es porque pasamos hasta el
84 tampoco lo es el 85 podemos concluir
que tampoco lo es porque 84 más 14 no
nos va a dar 85 por lo tanto el 85
tampoco es un múltiplo de 14 entonces mi
único número de estos que es múltiplo de
14 sería el 70 porque 14 por 123 45 14
por 5 me das 70 ya está aquí tenemos
estos dos problemas y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo